Amigos, atentos a esta pregunta:
Si pudierais escoger entre vivir la vida de
una de las personas más ricas y poderosas
del mundo hace 300 o 400 años; como, por
ejemplo podría ser George Washington;
o por el contrario, vivir la vida de hoy, de una personal normal y corriente,
de una persona de clase media
hoy en países como Nueva Zelanda, Dinamarca
o Canadá ¿con qué os quedaríais?
Puede que muchos tengáis la tentación de
responder muy rápido que, sin duda alguna,
de poder escoger os quedaríais siempre con
la vida del más pudiente, del más rico ¿Verdad?
Pues, si habéis escogido esa opción amigos…
no tengo nada claro que lo hayáis pensado bien...
Me explico: aceptar la vida de una de esa
súper fortunas históricas os supondría
renunciar a cosas tan elementales como el
aire acondicionado, internet, los teléfonos
móviles, el cine, la pizza y bueno, prácticamente
cualquier cosa que hoy consideramos indispensable
en nuestras vidas.
Y, por supuesto, tendriaís que aceptar una
esperanza de vida mucho, pero que mucho, más
corta.
Fijaos, por ejemplo, en la descripción que
el economista Xavier Sala i Martin hace de
la vida de Mansa Musa I de Malí, que, ojo,
a precios actuales es considerado como la
persona más rica de todos los tiempos:
“Mansa Musa tardó varios meses en recorrer
a caballo los 5.000 kilómetros que separan
Malí de la Meca, un viaje que un avión moderno
realiza en unas 6h y media. Sus palacios no
tenían aire acondicionado, no tenían acceso
a Google y sus hijos no podían jugar con
la Playstation o la Wii. Para comunicarse
con su colega el sultán an-Nasir de El Cairo,
Mansa Musa no tenía WhatsApp, ni Facebook
ni teléfono móvil. Por supuesto nunca pudo
tomarse una aspirina cuando tenía dolor de
cabeza”. Xavier Sala i Martín, Profesor
de economía en la Universidad de Columbia..
Y no penséis que hace 100 años la cosa era
mucho mejor. Por aquel entonces, John Rockefeller,
el conocido magnate del petróleo, no podía
ver la televisión, escuchar la radio ni usar
antibióticos. Todos estos “lujos”, simplemente
no existían.
Sí, así es, amigos, yo lo tengo claro. De
poder escoger, me quedo con la vida de clase
media de nuestros días.
Nada de viajes al pasado. Eso de que tiempos
pasados fueron siempre fueron mejores… pues
como que no.
Claro que, a decir verdad, todo esto tampoco
puede sorprendernos.
Al fin y al cabo, la innovación y el desarrollo
tecnológico han sido siempre uno de los principales
motores para mejorar la calidad de vida de
todas las personas.
Pues bien, respecto a todo esto, tengo una
buena noticia… y también, lo siento, una mala.
La buena es que todo apunta a que estamos
a las puertas de una nueva época de cambios
revolucionarios, cambios propios de las novelas
de ciencia ficción.
(Coches y camiones que conducen solos, biotecnología,
robótica, nanotecnología, inteligencia artificial
o simplemente la capacidad de compartir masivamente
el conocimientos a través de la nube.
En los próximos años todo apunta a que vamos
a poder experimentar muchos, pero que muchos
cambios en nuestras vidas.)
La mala noticia, amigos, es que por otro lado,
muchos expertos afirman que tanto la velocidad
como la profundidad de los cambios, se están
ralentizando desde hace décadas. Es decir,
que todos estos milagros tecnológicos podrían
tardar mucho en llegar… o incluso no hacerlo nunca.
EL FRENAZO
Los últimos 20 años del siglo XIX y los
primeros 50 del siglo XX fueron algo así
como la edad dorada de la innovación.
Los cambios que se produjeron en esas pocas
décadas fueron tan grandes que incluso hoy
parecen una especie de milagro.
Fijaos, en ese tiempo se desarrollaron tecnologías
como el automóvil, los aviones, los antibióticos,
la electricidad, la energía nuclear, los
insecticidas... y una larga, pero que muy
larga lista de cosas que cambiaron para siempre
la vida del ser humano.
Tantos cambios consiguieron que en poco más
de 50 años, la humanidad pasara de de moverse
a caballo -y, ojo, cuando se tenía la fortuna
de tener uno - a visitar, ni más ni menos
que la luna.
Fijaos en la evolución, por ejemplo de los
aviones, que pasaron de ser algo así a principios
del siglo XX.
A cosas así en la década de los 50.
O, echemos un vistazo a cómo han cambiado
los coches. Así eran al principio.
Y así en los 50.
Por pensar, incluso podemos pensar en el microondas,
una tecnología que en poco tiempo pasó de
ser una teoría, a ser utilizada en grandes
paneles de radar y finalmente a estar en las
cocinas de prácticamente todas las casas.
También, la Luz que pasó de las velas a
las bombillas;
La farmacia con el descubrimiento de los antibióticos
Las comunicaciones, donde en poco tiempo se
pasó de la paloma mensajera al telégrafo
primero y al teléfono poco después...
En otras palabras, hablamos de un desarrollo
impresionante.
Sin embargo desde entonces… bueno, digamos
las cosas han mejorado pero tampoco tanto:
(Los aviones siguen siendo básicamente los
mismo aviones, más seguros, más capaces
y más confortables, eso sí, pero básicamente
hablamos de la misma tecnología mejorada.
De hecho, podemos decir, que el único campo
donde se han producido muchas innovaciones
disruptivas ha sido en el mundo digital.)
Así que aquí, amigos, la pregunta que tenemos
que responder es ¿qué ha pasado? ¿Por qué
en el mundo digital las cosas van a toda máquina
y en otros campos no tanto?
Pues… algunas personas, como Peter Thiel,
lo tienen muy claro.Atentos:
(“Creo que hemos tenido mucha innovación
en computadoras, tecnologías de la información,
Internet, Internet móvil… en el mundo de
los Bits. No tanto en el mundo de los átomos,
viajes supersónicos, viajes espaciales, nuevas
formas de energía, medicina, etc. [...] Yo
diría que vivimos en un mundo en el que los
bits no fueron regulados mientras que los
átomos si fueron regulados”. Peter Thiel.)
Un momento, ¿está diciendo Peter Thiel que
algunas malas regulaciones están frenando
la innovación?
Pues… ¿sabéis qué? No es el único.
(No son pocos los expertos que defienden que
la innovación lleva años enfrentándose
a lo que podríamos denominar como una tormenta
casi perfecta.
Una tormenta compuesta entre otras cosas por
exceso de regulaciones, armonizaciones, patentes
y mucha, demasiada prudencia.)
Y, ojo,amigos, porque cuando hablamos de frenar
la innovación, tenemos que ser claros, hablamos
ni más ni menos que de frenar el progreso.
Ralentizar o frenar tecnologías que podrían
mejorar mucho nuestras vidas, desde la cura
contra el cáncer a… quien sabe… vuelos
espaciales.
¿PARALIZADOS POR EL MIEDO?
Sí, es verdad, la regulación suele tener
como objetivo mejorar la seguridad y la calidad
de vida para los ciudadanos.
Pero una cosa son los objetivos y otra los
resultados.
No pocas veces los políticos se olvidan que
las regulaciones también tienen consecuencias
negativas… y desde luego si hay muchas regulaciones,
las consecuencias pueden ser muy negativas.
Echemos un vistazo, por ejemplo, a lo que
ocurre con la investigación farmacéutica
en la Unión Europea, que desde luego en materia
de regulaciones es todo un campeón mundial.
(Todos sabemos lo importante que es la investigación
médica y farmaceútica y cómo puede mejorar
nuestras vidas.
Pues bien, la enorme regulación hace que
desarrollar un nuevo medicamento pueda costar
más de diez años.
Y no solo hablamos del tiempo que le supone
a los laboratorios cumplir con toda la normativa,
sino que, incluso cuando finalmente obtienen
la autorización de la Agencia Europea de
Medicamentos, aún tiene que esperar por culpa
de la burocracia un año más para llevar
su producto al mercado.)
Y, amigos, todo esto, claro, tiene consecuencias:
Por un lado retrasa muchísimo los procesos
de innovación, que en gran medida, no lo
olvidemos, se basan en la experiencia.
Por otro, encarecen mucho la investigación.
Claro, hablamos de 10 o 12 años invirtiendo
mucho dinero y sin posibilidad de ganar absolutamente
nada…
Ojo, sí, está claro, la prudencia y garantizar
la seguridad es algo muy importante…
¿Pero 10 o 12 años por culpa de una burocracia
excesiva?
Puede, amigos que nos estemos pasando.
Y luego, hay otro detalle… que no podemos
olvidar: el privilegio de monopolio que, de
alguna forma, todas estas regulaciones crean
para las grandes multinacionales farmacéuticas.
Sí, tal cual como lo escucháis. Las grandes
beneficiadas por toda esta hiperregulación
son… precisamente, las grandes farmacéuticas.
Claro… si los pequeños laboratorios no
pueden hacer frente a todos estos costes,
y el mercado cambia menos porque hay menos
innovación pues… digamos que las grandes
tienen un negocio seguro,bien grande y estable.
Pero no es sólo la industria farmacéutica..para
nada… la de los juguetes o la industria
agrícola también se ven muy afectadas, por
ejemplo.
(Y además está también la inseguridad jurídica
que supone invertir mucho dinero en un proyecto
de investigación a 10 años vista y que de
repente se aprueben nuevas regulaciones que
cambian las reglas del juego.)
Insisto, muchas regulaciones son importantes,
pero hay que tener mucho cuidado con la hiperregulación…
porque cuando sumamos muchas exigencias al
final lo que hacemos es encarecer y frenar
el proceso que más mejora la vida de todas
las personas: la innovación.
Otro buen ejemplo lo tenemos con la tecnología
móvil.
¿Sabeis que que ya en los años 40 comenzó
a desarrollarse esta tecnología? Sí, así
es. Todo esto de la comunicación móvil no
es tan nuevo como parece.
En la década de los 40 comenzó a desarrollarse
el MTS, el servicio de telefonía móvil,
un estándar que utiliza ondas de radio para
conectar un teléfono fijo con otro móvil.
Pero claro… puede que os estéis preguntando
¿Qué diantres pasó para que esta tecnología
tardase tanto en madurar?
Al fin y al cabo no fue hasta finales de los
80 cuando aparecieron los primeros teléfonos
Pues… la respuesta, amigos, pasa por la
clase política y las regulaciones.
Veréis, la Comisión Federal de Comunicaciones
de Estados Unidos administra por ley y concede
las licencias para usar el llamado “espectro
radioeléctrico,
esto es el medio por el cual se transmiten
las frecuencias de radio electromagnéticas,
es decir, las señales, que permiten las telecomunicaciones.
Pues bien, mirad lo que pasó:
(Cuando las empresas estaban invirtiendo en
desarrollar la tecnología móvil allá por
los años 50… esta Comisión Federal de
las Comunicaciones, al fin y al cabo un órgano
político, decidió que todo eso de la telefonía
móvil no era muy importante y que el espectro
radioeléctrico tenía que usarse para potenciar
otra tecnología naciente: la televisión,
que era mucho más útil.
Esto ya es algo que puede ser discutible…
pero el caso es que se asigno mucho espectro
a las televisiones, bastante más de lo que
necesitaban.)
Vamos, que lo cierto es que las 2 tecnologías
hubiesen podido desarrollarse al tiempo…
pero el regulador, los políticos,  simplemente no le vio futuro a esto de las comunicaciones móviles.
(Y ahí no acaba todo… en 1973, el VicePresidente
de Motorola, Marty Cooper, que es considerado
el padre del teléfono móvil, hizo la primera
llamada con uno de estos dispositivos que
hoy todos conocemos. Sí,¡ en los años 70!
Pero una vez más, amigos, intervino el regulador
que consideraba que bueno, que en esto de
la telefonía móvil la competencia no era
posible y había que asignarle el monopolio
a la American Telecom.)
Para entendernos, podemos decir que los políticos,
los reguladores, no dieron ni una y retrasaron
más de 40 años el desarrollo de las comunicaciones
móviles.
Esto es en Estados Unidos… pero en Europa…
bueno la cosa en general transcurría por
una camino similar.
Y todo esto es normal, amigos, porque la investigación
y la innovación es cosa de científicos y
emprendedores… no de políticos.
De hecho, este es el problema de muchos de
los programas de I+D+i públicas que no funcionan
porque su trabajo viene determinado por políticos
y burócratas…
Lo hemos contado aquí en VisualPolitik, los
gobiernos pueden jugar un papel destacado
en promover la I+D+i pero lo tienen que hacer
siendo conscientes de sus limitaciones.
Es lo que hicieron en Israel, lo hemos visto
aquí, con el programa Yozma, darle el liderazgo
a los inversores, a los emprendedores y a
los científicos que operan en un mercado
en competencia.
Si no se hace esto, los programas y las ayudas
públicas pueden ser incluso contraproducentes:
pueden elevar los costes de la I+D+i, dificultar
la tarea de las startups y, en definitiva,
frenar el desarrollo tecnológico y la innovación
que son las mejores formas de incrementar
la calidad de vida de todos nosotros.
Pero… dicho esto, turno para ti ¿Qué países
piensas que liderarán la carrera tecnológica?
Déjanos tu respuesta en los comentarios y
también en esta encuesta.
Si te ha resultado interesante el vídeo dale
a like y ayúdanos a compartirlo.
Por cierto, muchas gracias a nuestro amigo
Víctor que nos ha ayudado un montón con
la preparación de este vídeo. Victor ¡gracias!
Ahora sí, un saludo y hasta la próxima.